this is the Dave Ramsey show we're glad
you're with us America thank you for
joining us I'm talking with heading into
the break I was talking with Sharon in
Sarasota Florida and 68 years old 20
years ago they bought a universal life
policy which is a type of cash value
policy a portion of your premium folks
when you have a universal policy goes to
pay the insurance cost and the insurance
is cost goes up every single year
because it's based on annual renewable
term rates and so more and more is going
to insurance cost as the policy gets
older less and less is going to the
investment to the point that they cross
the line a few years ago and contacted
Sharon and her husband and said oh now
the premium that you're paying 100
percent of it won't cover the insurance
cost so now if you want to keep the
insurance not only is 0 going to
investments but now even more has to be
paid to keep the insurance active and
that's how far we got in the discussion
is what I just said all correct Sharon
yes okay and what is the face amount of
this policy
eighty thousand eighty thousand dollars
and how much money do you all have how
much money do we have how much you in
your 401ks and your now we do have
retirement accounts a total eighty four
thousand we have a ten thousand dollar
emergency fund we are debt free or have
to pay for good so this is kind of like
so you don't have that how much is how
much cash value is in this right now
it's a six thousand okay so and do you
have pension plans as well no okay and
so you're living on Social Security and
eighty thousand dollars or the 401 K my
husband still works he I he has 36
thousand in income and he brings in
twenty-one thousand in Social Security
okay I don't look gotcha in the face
amount of this policy you said was
eighty thousand dollars
yeah okay we did look into term
insurance for him but number one it's
really a lot more expensive at his age
but number two he
battled cancer a couple times yeah
non-hodgkins lymphoma and so basically
nobody will touch it yeah very difficult
very difficult we don't know we can
lower the death benefit so what is the
premium how much is it a year how much
77 a month yep okay all right so 800 a
year and you make $36,000 a year well
here's that here's the equation here's
the way it works in your mind okay the
purpose of this is to give you an extra
$80,000 if he dies before you do okay
and so is that worth 800 bucks at this
stage it's there's no investment value
whatsoever so we're not gonna the only
question is you know you you don't have
a huge nest egg you've got a small nest
egg and so to double it basically if he
were to die would be very helpful mm-hmm
and so keeping the insurance sounds
really good with that in mind you know
they told us it would only last another
three or four years anyway only 71 or 72
okay and they're gonna make you stop
anyway they're gonna pull the plug on oh
yeah okay and at that point you would
cash it out and whatever cash value is
in there my husband would like to get it
out now
yeah no way to get it out no way to get
it out now it's close the policy down
right which means that you would you
know if he passes away you'd have the
401k money the paid for house and be
living on Social Security right yeah but
you probably can make it cuz I got a
feeling you guys are frugal people oh
yeah so you probably could make it on
that but it's not going to be a dream
come true
so they have given you notice that at 62
or I'm sorry 73 or whatever 70 years old
they're gonna shut the policy down
regardless yeah well I guess well no I
guess if we could keep paying you know
at this point it would be over 200 a
month yeah I think we could keep it
going but okay or we could lower the
death benefit
and keep it going they told us we could
do that which is what I wanted to do but
he wanted to cash it out so so we're
doing nothing yeah there's not a great
answer okay that's why I'm aiming and
hauling a little bit I'm trying to think
through it my tendency is at eight
hundred bucks a year right now to keep
it for a while okay
seventy seven dollars a month even if
you use the cash values you can have the
cash values to begin to pay the premium
mm-hm and do you know it's going to do
it's going to use up some of that eight
thousand dollars I'm probably going to
do that and let the eight thousand
dollars pay the premium starting today
and I'm probably going to leave it in
place a couple of years when it starts
being two hundred a month instead of
seventy seven a month at that point I'm
probably going to join his tribe and say
let's cash it out mm-hmm and close it
down but I don't think it's gonna make
sense to keep this long for a long long
time
we're probably gonna keep a couple more
years how's his health what's that how
is his health oh well he's the first
time I went through he stayed
cancer-free for five years and this time
he has been cancer-free for two years do
it so I mean he goes in and gets at
scans every every six months or so to
make sure it's not coming back so they
can stay aggressive with it good good
I'm glad to hear that well yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna let the cash value pay
the premiums for the next two years and
keep it open if and I'm gonna check on
his health at that time let's say that
he's got another episode with cancer
going at that time then you pay the
premium no matter what it costs and you
keep it open if he if he's doing if the
cancer has come back at any stage right
you keep you keep the thing open at that
point but if he's doing really really
good and everything's clean and two
years from now you haven't seen a spot
nothing's no problems anywhere I'm
probably dropping it at that point okay
does that make sense to you he wouldn't
he wouldn't be insured so yeah you know
but um but but you're also not paying
you know three thousand two thousand
dollars a year which is what it's going
to be at that point
which is starting to be ridiculous with
that kind of money you could throw money
into investments and start having some
money and but but at this stage I'm I'm
hesitant to cancel it it's it's
obviously a bad policy it's obviously
been a bad thing but it's your only
option you're stuck with it so that
makes it hard to discuss and hard to
think about but I'm gonna hold it two
years about the cash value pay it at the
end of that time if he's healthy and
still cancer-free I'm dropping it
otherwise I'm gonna keep it if if he's
got a health issue at that time so good
question thank you for calling in and
I'm sorry you had this problem folks you
hear me yell and scream about cash value
life insurance whole life life insurance
universal life variable life is a ripoff
you just experienced it you just
experienced the back end what happens if
you buy one of those pieces of crap
policy and you're 68 years old this is
what happens because the money they put
into that stupid butt policy would be
300 grand right now in mutual funds if
they did put it into that into a good
investment instead of getting ripped off
by this insurance company and if she was
sitting there with 300 grand plus the
other 401k they'd have about four
hundred thousand bucks plus their house
is paid for
she wouldn't even have called me but
instead guess who's fat and sassy
instead of her the insurance company so
when your whole life agent says I don't
really agree with Dave Ramsey it's
because your whole life agents trying to
rip you off
that's why your whole life agents saying
that and there's only two kinds of whole
life agents ignorant and crooked because
if you understand these numbers and that
story right there and then you still
sell this stuff that makes you crooked
you ought to be ashamed of yourself and
if you don't understand these numbers
and you're still selling that stuff that
makes you ignorant and you shouldn't be
selling this stuff and by the way folks
in case you didn't know
you'll get screwed and what way more
often by an enthusiastic ignoramus
then you will buy a con-artist so most
of people out there selling this crap
are enthusiastic ignoramuses they're not
actual con artists
my uncle Charlie sold me this was an
enthusiastic ignoramus
that's all uncle Charlie we just nailed
him right there
because he's probably not a crook if
he'd actually sat down looked and
realized that sharing your if your
friend if Sharon's friend sold her that
he's not a friend a friends like that
you don't need enemies you know she
could had 300 grand and mutual funds
easy for them what they've dumped into
this crappy product whole life life
insurance the payday lender of the
middle class
I agree veyts me this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]